total et j'ai décidé de mettre en avant
les le tout si kabila et il est ici cas
du sénat haïtien et comme vous savez en
martinique dont ils connaissent la
musique la peinture haïtienne mais il
connaît pas le modèle les vêtements
traditionnels haïtiens dans la raison
pour laquelle j'ai décidé de montrer ça
cette année à au peuplement tunique est
alors il y aura de la musique qui aura
de la poésie il y aura qu est-ce qu il y
aura donc les 18 octobre 1 il y aura
normalement dans un premier lieu du 8
heures du matin à 18 heures il y aura
normalement en une exposition et une
exposition sur les vêtements
traditionnels haïti et des 18-30 ans à
dix à vingt ans donc normalement il y
aura un moment de musique avec francky
joseph moi même et mes amis mes invités
par exemple à gabriel sioui nice et
ajami elle j'en ai ensuite on va
terminer c'était soirée par une
conférence la dengue est le king la
bibliothèque schoelcher est un endroit
emblématique incertain on doit vraiment
extraordinaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai décidé d comme on dit lieu
comme on dit les tissus carabine à haïti
là il dit à la bibliothèque schoelcher